utilise jamais des IRM dossier leur cas leur
nourriture ouais il n'y a pas ici
c'est gros ouais
je vois de ça laissez Fidel comme une
[ __ ] droite désolé mais nous ne l'écrivons pas pour moi
ah
donc il y a un gamin de nez incroyable
ouais nous partons maintenant  pétition et nous
nous dirigeons vers le bonus aussi d'accord et n'attendez
pas de type sud-ouest qui était un zéro
hé arrêtez mais chérie c'est mon pote
populaire mais
quand la glace a protégé Titus le verre
ici la montagne et de l'ours de glace
ici sur la droite, vous pouvez couper ceux-ci sont
le droit particulier que je viens de passer, vous deviendrez
plus profond
car vous connaissez les océans jusqu'au sommet à nouveau oh
mon
Hey
Evon
mr.  Je vais en jeter des dizaines avec de l'
acidité d'oeuf
Je ne vais rien faire oh ouais mais toi
à la drogue mais alors c'est clair lequel